There's a wealth of hidden treasures in Mamma
Mia 2 for fans to enjoy, with little connections,
nods and winks to costumes, choreography,
music, jokes, and more from the first film.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and in this video I'm going to reveal 10 amazing
details you may have missed in the Mamma Mia
sequel which will make you love it even more!
The special connection between Donna and Sophie,
and the parallels between the two characters,
are at the heart of Here We Go Again.
For example, there's a delightful link back
to young Donna's silver butterfly necklace
in the christening scene where Sophie wears
a dress with a butterfly pattern.
The film's costume designer chose that particular
design as the idea was that Sophie was wearing
the dress in memory of her mother.
The horseshoe necklace that Sophie wears in
the sequel is also a sweet and subtle link
back to her mother and how her experience
on the island changed her life.
The first night young Donna stayed in the
old farmhouse on the hill, there was a big
storm which frightened a horse in the stables.
Taking care of that scared horse not only
brought a young Sam into Donna's life, but
also ultimately led her to open the hotel.
That's because Sofia, who owned the building,
believed you could "judge a person's heart
by the way they treat animals", and the fact
that Donna was so kind to Sofia's horse Hector
led her to offer the old farmhouse to Donna
to live in for free if she did it up.
Remember Bill and Sophie's conversation in
the first film after he realised he might
be her father.
"You know what comes next?"
"You're not going to tell me you have a twin
sister, are you?"
Well, Here We Go Again gives an amusing explanation
for Bill's reaction in the original film.
As we find out in the sequel, Bill himself
has a twin brother, who pretends to be Bill
at a prestigious award ceremony so the real
Bill can go to the opening party for Sophie's
hotel on the same night.
When young Donna gets chased by a goat during
The Name of the Game scene, it feels like
a little nod back to the first film when Meryl
Streep's Donna was surprised by a goat while
singing Mamma Mia!
In the original film, Sam, Harry, and Bill
stayed in the old goathouse when Sophie tried
to hide them from her mother when they first
arrived on the island.
And I also wonder whether the "really amusing
story" about a goat that Bill's twin brother
wanted to tell at the awards ceremony had
anything to do with the goats at Sofia's old
farmhouse.
Remember that Sofia was actually Bill and
his brother's great-aunt.
"Well, I'm named after a Sofia."
"I used to have a great-aunt living on the
mainland named Sofia."
A crucial piece of Donna's wardrobe in the
first movie was her denim dungarees, and the
sequel shows their origin.
But even before young Donna purchases her
signature outfit in the new film, the costume
department cleverly lays the trail for that
moment, dressing Lily James in denim shorts
and bikini, blue tops, denim jackets, and,
later in the film, denim flares.
And the Dynamos' "When I Kissed The Teacher"
outfits also have an interesting origin.
If you look really closely in Donna's student
room in Oxford, you'll notice there's some
material missing from the brown, yellow, and
cream-striped curtains.
The idea was to hint at the inventiveness
of Donna, Tanya, and Rosie who made their
outfits themselves out of those very curtains.
The concept for the Dynamos' cut-out curtain
clothes was inspired by movies such as Gone
With The Wind, The Sound Of Music, and Enchanted.
And costume designer Michele Clapton added
"stuck-on stars and fake-fur boas" to enhance
the 70s vibe.
Here We Go Again features some really fun
call-backs to the choreography in the first
film.
For example, at the very end of the dance
routine for "When I Kissed The Teacher", the
frame freezes on young Donna as she's about
to dive-bomb into the river, just as we saw
Meryl Streep's Donna do at the end of "Dancing
Queen" in the first film, though Streep did
actually jump in!
According to writer-director Ol Parker, the
reason we don't get to see the Dynamos jump
into the water is that it would have held
up filming as the actresses would have got
soaked and needed lots of time to fix their
hair and clothes again for each take.
So, instead, they jumped onto a crash pad
that's out of shot!
And there's another cool call-back during
the dance routine for "Why Did It Have To
Be Me?"
when young Donna pinches Bill's hat and pops
it on her own head, just like Meryl Streep's
Donna did to the ship's captain during her
performance of Money Money Money in the original
film.
It was really beautiful how Meryl Streep and
Amanda Seyfried's choreography during "My
Love, My Life" mirrored their performance
during "Slipping Through My Fingers" in the
first film.
Each scene takes place at a very emotional
point in the story.
Donna sings Slipping Through My Fingers as
she helps Sophie get ready for her wedding,
and the way they stand together here coincides
with the song's lyrics, 'Sometimes I wish
that I could freeze the picture and save it
from the funny tricks of time.'
Mamma Mia 2 calls back to that image of them
in front of the mirror when Donna makes her
first appearance reflected in the chapel's
baptismal font, and as they join together
singing My Love, My Life, the lyrics 'Like
reflections of your mind' feel especially
fitting.
There's a lovely bit of musical symmetry between
the sequel and the first film.
In the original movie, after the curtain call
performance of Waterloo, Amanda Seyfried's
version of "Thank You For The Music" plays
over the closing credits.
And the sequel mirrors this as Seyfried again
sings Thank You For The Music, this time as
Sophie writes invitations for the hotel's
opening party.
And there's another delightful musical connection
between the beginning of each film.
In the sequel, when Sophie tells Cienfuegos
that she needs him to make sure the place
is ready for the party rather than post the
invites, he replies, 'Whatever you dream,
Miss Sophie, we'll make real.'
Which is a nice link back to the original
movie which began and ended with Sophie singing
"I Have A Dream", first as she posted letters
to her three potential fathers and later as
she left her dads and mum behind on the island
to travel with her boyfriend Sky.
Now if you want to know about the important
changes Mamma Mia 2 made to the original Mamma
Mia story tap in the top right to check out
that video.
And let me know in the comments which moments
you loved most in Here We Go Again and any
other details or connections between the two
movies.
So, how many of these details did you spot
when you first saw the film?
And did you notice any other cool details
or connections?
For a chance to win one of these awesome Mamma
Mia 2 merch packs, make sure you subscribe,
leave me a comment about the film, and also
tap the Gleam link in the video description
below to register your entry.
Tap left to watch my full Mamma Mia and musicals
playlist or tap right for another video you're
sure to like.
If you enjoyed this, I really appreciate a
thumbs-up!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!